let's talk about the gate let's talk
about the ravens the ravens are
incredible mike and guess what i want to
actually i want to i want to start here
and get in front of something i famously
said i was
wondering if the ravens were frauds in
september when they were two and two
remember back in september this ravens
team got smoked by the browns and got
run all over in baltimore two and two
they have not lost since that moment
they're on a franchise record 10 game
winning streak now mike
the fact that the ravens i think last
night they punted four times that was
the second time all year that they
punted more than three times in a game
they basically made the punting position
obsolete by being an unbelievable
offense and going forward on fourth down
and being aggressive this reminds me
mike of
watching a uh a superior versus inferior
college football game when the ravens
play some of these opponents like last
night the spread was 17. and it wasn't
crazy to take the ravens which is almost
unheard of in the nfl and that's how
good they are and that's how much
they're rolling
yeah i've said all year that for
whatever reason nfl bettors can't get
comfortable with the idea of 13 14 15 16
17 point spreads and there are a lot of
these games where i think the spread
isn't as big as it should be that the
gap is much bigger than the average
better will acknowledge an nfl game
would ever have that kind of gap but we
have seen it time and again this year we
saw it last night the 21-point victory
the cover although the jets had a chance
the jets had a chance to get enough
points to get to get within the margin
they they ultimately didn't pull it off
and you know the other thing about the
ravens
um
and and this is why i believe next year
they will be on prime time the maximum
number of times allowable by league
rules and when they're not in prime time
games they're going to be 4 25 p.m
eastern on cbs or fox i think that lamar
jackson has
has the gift of getting people to keep
watching even after the game is no
longer worth watching you want to watch
and see what lamar jackson is going to
do next
yeah i absolutely agree and a little
bonus you get the nostalgic run of rg3
when lamar jackson when they get to the
40-point mark and they're like all right
we're going to take lamar jackson off
out last night rg3 comes in and
everyone's watching because you know
there's there's uh rg3 had his moment in
time that i think everyone looks back on
somewhat fondly unless you're maybe a
redskins fan or a member of the shanahan
family but this was uh yeah i mean it is
must watch tv when the ravens are
playing and the way they score with ease
it it really does look
like they shouldn't be on the same field
so much so mike i don't know if you saw
last night but lamar jackson it was like
uh a a card signing at center field er
at the 50-yard line after the game lamar
jackson was signing like every single
jersey for the jets everyone was lined
up they wanted to get a piece of lamar
jackson he's that type of transcendent
talent i posed this question on my
podcast mike is this part of my take a
little shout out adam sandler and kevin
garnett today is this the easiest choice
madden has ever had for a video game
cover lamar jackson on next year's
madden
oh it's it's a no-brainer it's
absolutely easy brainer
it's the easiest for that it's the
easiest mvp choice we've ever had i said
last night anybody who doesn't vote for
lamar jackson should have their votes
stripped of them and you know you may as
well get a piece of lamar jackson after
the game because you're not going to get
it during the game we were showing
highlights of the game there and a point
that we made on the little tv stub on
the way in he's learning how to run out
of bounds we had two consecutive plays
in that packet where he runs out of
bounds and that is smart and that is
wise and that is mature and that is what
lamar jackson needs to do aaron rodgers
told him that when they played in the
preseason get down slide get out of
bounds that's the way you are are able
to keep doing all those great things you
do now he did take a big pop right there
on the record-setting run when he passed
mike vick for the most yards by a
quarterback rushing in any season but
multiple occasions last night he chose
to get out of bounds and i think that if
once he works that in on a regular basis
you take away that element of well it's
just a matter of time until he gets
injured no it's not and here we are 14
games in and what what many thought
would have been inevitable back in
september has not happened yet and i
think that makes the ravens even more
dangerous going into the playoffs yeah
and you're absolutely right on the mvp
thing because when i think of mvps i
always want uh you know there people
have different definitions of mvp
usually it's going to be a guy from one
of the best teams but you could make the
argument that there are some middle of
the pack teams where there's one guy who
significantly uh needs you know deserves
more credit for that team's success but
my definition of mvp every single year
is i want to look back and say what was
that year about what was that year what
was a memorable thing from that year
patrick mahomes last year was
significant he was the memorable thing
you think of the 2018 nfl season you
think of patrick holmes the same goes
for lamar jackson this year he is the
story this year
it's really no like other than it's
basically the 49ers and lamar jackson
are kind of the two dueling stories for
the 2019 season of like what was the
thing that was most memorable obviously
there's the playoffs to write a bunch of
chapters here but in terms of regular
season those are the two stories and
lamar jackson is the singular story in
himself
and you know lamar jackson has been very
humble throughout his nfl career he he
doesn't care about individual
achievement individual records doesn't
care about mvp he just wants to win the
super bowl but last night he was very
happy to break the single season rushing
record for a quarterback that had been
held by mike vick since 2006 with 1039
yards lamar jackson sailed past it last
night after the game he was asked about
what it meant to him to break fix record
here he is
[Music]
it's pretty cool um
my favorite player growing up um but
it's amazing and i'm gonna cherish that
forever
and just gotta keep it going right you
know records meant to be broken like he
said i heard him say that and it's an
honor for me to do it
yeah and you know here's the thing about
vic and people have been comparing
jackson to vic jackson is better than
vic ever was the year that vic had 1039
yards rushing he wasn't an mvp candidate
if you go back and look at his game by
game stats that year he was so
wildly inconsistent that was the year
that he flipped off the fans at the
georgia dome after a late season game
because they were booing him they were
upset with the fact that the falcons
lost it was not a good year for the
falcons that season yes he got 1039
yards but that's the only thing that was
worth talking about lamar jackson is the
complete package he can run he can throw
his team is good around him and they're
making the most out of his skills and
abilities the offense has been designed
specifically for him remember that
narrative last year big cat that when
teams get a second shot at lamar jackson
it's all going to be dramatically
different now only one team's gotten a
second shot at him this year the bengals
not that that matters the browns get
their second shot next week and they
beat him in week four somehow but i no
one's talking about that well the second
time through it'll be a lot different no
it's not going to be any different
because nobody can come up with a way to
stop this guy because physically the
other players don't have the abilities
to get close to him well
now let's pump the brakes here for a
second because i
mike florio would you say that you'd be
shocked if we are sitting here in the
middle of january and it's a friday or
it's a monday and the new england
patriots have beaten the baltimore
ravens in the playoffs because bill
belichick who has taken down some of the
best offensive minds in the game figured
out a way to stop lamar jackson i mean
that's
i agree with you that it is
nearly impossible to stop lamar jackson
at this point but if there's one guy i
mean we said the same thing when the
greatest show on turf looked like they
were going to score a billion points in
that super bowl there's one guy who
could probably figure out a way his
second shot at him
it's it's the guy in new england who's
who's won six rings he's got six rings
on his hands wouldn't you say yeah
yeah i don't know that he has the
offense to compliment whatever we come
up with defensively and i'm gonna go
back i'm gonna go back 11 years before
the greatest show on turf i mean he's
the guy that came up with the game plan
that took down the k-gun offense yes
so this is right so so i agree with you
that the patriots offense has been
abysmal and there are big big issues and
i don't know if they'll be able to pull
the weight but in terms of a team out
there that they might have to face for
the second time
the new england patriots are sitting
there
and it's definitely different when you
go up against bill belichick the second
time in a year so i wouldn't i wouldn't
i wouldn't put those ravens strictly i
wouldn't throw them into the super bowl
just yet although they clearly are the
best team the most consistent team in
the afc and that's been the case for two
and a half months now and no one's even
come close to touching them
and let me let me put this out there uh
because it's an interesting dilemma the
ravens are going to face potentially in
week 17 if they lock up the number one
see there was a report yesterday for
mike they're a follower of nfl media
that they're considering sitting lamar
jackson week 17 against the steelers
and i i don't like that because if the
steelers need to win that game to get in
and maybe by then they won't so it won't
matter i think the ravens need to do
everything they can to knock the
steelers out because before you would
have that return date with the patriots
in the afc championship game there's a
possibility that the steelers come
rolling into baltimore and that's the
last team i think the ravens want to see
at any point in the playoffs because
they don't care about lamar jackson
they're not intimidated by anybody they
almost beat the ravens earlier in the
year a game that went to overtime the
game where mason rudolph got knocked out
on his feet and and maybe they'll maybe
they'll they'll beat him week 17 if he
ends up playing in the game i don't want
to see the steelers because i think mike
tomlin could come up with something not
necessarily the game plan but getting
his guys into a mindset where just by
sheer force of will and physicality they
find a way to outscore the ravens so i
don't want to mess with them either and
i'm going to knock them out if i can if
i'm the ravens i don't know i i think
you you would not want to take your
chances against one of the best if not
the best uh defenses
in the nfl right now the pittsburgh
steelers i think i would probably sit
lamar jackson if you've got nothing to
play for just just let the chips fall
where they may after that and make sure
you're healthy going into january
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports